on 21 points it it's looking good for  him to qualify but he's not a hundred  percent this is not going to be a good  loss for him  and look at report that is really  sadistic just stopping the white king  from move well okay it's only got one  square now um the white Bishop can't  move the white Rook can't move  oh he's gonna go for checkmate oh he's  coming in yeah and uh I guess the plan  would be  just to walk the king rugby three is  nice and now the max C3 discovered Jack  yes that's it Checkmate next move once  the white king goes into the corner the  Rapport takes the win it's over wow  three important points for Richard's  report to taking to the same score as  Arjun erasi both now on 21 points that  is bad news four player like Anish Geary  all right well uh David we came in very  late  and it looked like maybe Arjun was  saving